Wow good wide against Wolverine that
doesn't happen too often and so I'm
going for quite double the fee and
shadow setup let's see what he does
Kari just posed to some symmetrical
English or is he doing something else 94
for example is an interesting move here
[Music]
okay wow really
okay
[Music]
and then start with that then if or next
okay
[Music]
yeah a six is the worst possible square
for the knight really is just absolutely
nothing to do here I can go to c7 and
then looking at the d5 pawn and so on
hmm okay let's go here Joe that's nice
very nice control and she's got the
terrible piece on a 6 ok you're good
center here right so let's check first
and then go a 5 yeah that's an excellent
position
I watched you control all those entry
squares Wow
okay I know that I never guess any of
his moves h5 Wow
so what happens interesting question if
I should take him okay let's do that to
4G for a 94 and I can take on g4 with 94
really really annoying so okay I can now
enter them or see if I have something
better
my Scott f5 maybe a f5 or something
Jeff so let's enter Queen f5 I have from
Queen edge form is one good move and I
can also take this six not quite sure
probably taking these six is stronger
yeah he only has Group B 6 and then
Queen g3 it's very good for wide I'm
also threatening rookie 7 yeah okay I'm
not sure how good this really is a
thought it would be even better but
rupee it doesn't seem so clear I give up
I really give up I never guess any of
his moves why hello cookie 7 why would
you do that
so so with a cheeky 41 Quincy fork f7s
is an immediate win
I can go Queen a5 okay Queenie five I
will take take a seven probably
Jimmy but maybe he has to do that
what what what else is them yeah okay
okay seven
oh wait wait wait not not let's not be
too quick here
I'm think a little bit shaking d6 is
going with b6 which is not bad but okay
[Music]
why is it taking c4 now that might be
interesting
[Music]
well it's it's interesting
[Music]
can I go look e7 that's difficult to
calculate with that limited time let's
do it
Queen g6 isn't it a threat now it's got
checks this is irritating
Quincy one baby is called Quincy one and
then our Quincy one I can actually play
Bishop f1 that's strong check ok here
you had no check where's the check I
don't see a check queen g4 maybe she
doing that for checking me on age 5
where is the check
can cover can you cover just g6 but I
have rook f7 so here he's got this check
and he has got look h1 the combination
of both is irritating Queen on age 5
King g3 but then he has no check he's
got to check on b3 so I can check here
right
why not Sony this check their own h5
King G 3 rupees for check f3 and that's
it I don't see I don't see it don't see
a difference here Queenie 5 isn't
helping no check
he still mated him after Queenie five
with double rooks on the seventh yeah
then midnight on a six this is he put it
there early on which is basically really
as I said the worst possible square and
sometimes gets to you if you play a
piece down voluntarily black resigns
yeah it's a bit surprising I mean I
actually think that Bishop d7 is a bad
move anyway but if you now decide
between p8 and a5 you probably rather
want to go to a5 so at least you have
something with b5 and here I mean on a6
is the worst possible square here you
can can never go here you can go to c7
and from c7 you have nowhere else to go
it's just just a bad bad piece placement
yeah came and I just got a huge huge
play in the center yeah so and here yeah
I can I mean maybe I wanted to punish
him a little bit too hard with Knight H
- maybe I'm jarred like normal moves are
better like Knight H for something I
mean like it's really hard pressed to do
something like against this yeah let's
say I'm doubling on the e-file
and here's he has ridiculous pieces yeah
Knight on g7 knight on a 6
yeah probably this was a bit a bit too
too hard it is this compensation but
it's not a huge edge or something
Jack yeah yeah yeah computer gives equal
but with Bishop f5 okay
there should be five looky 7 Queen D and
an ith to g4 wasn't really great yeah it
looked like an interesting but it's not
really doing the trick
yeah I wonder here so rude so here you
have this is losing erich87 here Queen
d6 though okay not this move
what is the engine giving here slight
advantage check aya King different
Queenie voice interesting now okay I
didn't see that more the ideas that okay
I only saw that I'm winning a piece but
the D pawn is quite dangerous so he will
probably be able to promote that yeah
that that's probably wrong very likely
but here it's just override check no
check it's made in something according
to the competent made in six yeah the
easiest and the opening is just to just
to take it like here I'm just take it
and to take on d4 but should be some
here white gains space and it's really
debatable if this Knight is ever going
to have a good square to go to okay well
thanks for watching